[المتحدث 1]
حسناً. لست متأكداً تماماً لأنني لم أذهب إلى هناك من قبل أو ربما ذهبت بالفعل، لكنني سأحاول
الحصول على بعض المساعدة من شخص ما، أليس كذلك؟ شخص يمكنه مساعدتي لأنني شخص متقدم في السن. لذا
[المتحدث 1]
الأمور تكون أصعب علينا مقارنة بالشخص الشاب. لذا سأفعل ذلك.
[المتحدث 2]
سنطلب المساعدة. ستتصل بشخص ما على هاتفك أو يمكننا طلب المساعدة بصوت عالٍ.
[المتحدث 1]
نعم. نعم. لو كان هذا هو الموقف، سأطلب المساعدة بالفعل. نعم.
حسناً، يمكنك أن تقول "النجدة". "النجدة، فقط أخرجوني من هذا الفيضان."
[المتحدث 1]
كما تعلم، الأمر أشبه بأن يكون هناك ركود في الداخل لأنه نفق وبه،
في نهايته القصوى، نقاط مرتفعة. لذا يأتي الفيضان مباشرة بينهما
[المتحدث 1]
إلى داخل النفق ثم يخرج من النفق.
[المتحدث 2]
إنه مثل بركة ماء.
[المتحدث 1]
نعم. لم يكن الأمر كبركة يمكنك الذهاب إليها والسباحة فيها بالفعل. نعم. سأحتفظ بالأمل. سأطلب
المساعدة بالفعل. هذا ما سأفعله، كما تعلم، أو ربما إذا لم أتمكن من إيجاد مساعدة،
[المتحدث 1]
سأبدأ في الركض ومحاولة الإمساك بالأشياء من حولي حتى لا أقع، كما تعلم، في
الفيضان وأحاول الهروب من هناك.
[المتحدث 2]
لو فاض الماء، لكنت سأسبح لأنني أعرف كيف أسبح،
ولكن هل تعرف كيف تسبح؟
[المتحدث 1]
قليلاً فقط. تصيبني تشنجات كلما حاولت السباحة، لذا
أنا لا أحاول فعل ذلك لأن الأمر يصبح فظيعاً.
[المتحدث 2]
إذا لم تكن مضطراً، فلن تحاول.
[المتحدث 1]
نعم. وخاصة الماء، الفيضان، أعني، إنه نوعاً ما قذر في ذلك الجزء.
جميع الناس من بعض أنحاء المدينة، يُلقون (بمخلفاتهم) في ذلك الجزء. لذا أنا لا،
[المتحدث 1]
لا يُنصح بذلك.
[المتحدث 2]
أعتقد أن وضعاً افتراضياً أفضل سيكون أن تكون في مكان جيد
مع عائلتك، مكان ما آمن وتذهب فقط للحصول على طعام لتأكله.
[المتحدث 2]
يبدو هذا هو الوضع الافتراضي المثالي.
[المتحدث 1]
نعم، أتمنى لو كنت أكثر أماناً من ذلك.
[المتحدث 2]
إليك سؤال هنا. لقد نظرنا في بعض مفاتيح الحوار العامة
والأسئلة الافتراضية. دعنا نحاول ربط هذه بأفكارك الخاصة
[المتحدث 2]
والمحادثات المحتملة، الأشياء التي تود التحدث عنها.
لذا يمكننا أن نعود إلى مفاتيح الحوار هذه التي أجريناها والأسئلة الافتراضية
[المتحدث 2]
ونحاول التفكير في أكثر أنواع الأسئلة إثارة للاهتمام وكيف يمكننا
الإجابة على سؤال آخر في محادثة حقيقية. في أي نوع من المواقف ستستخدم هذه الأنواع
[المتحدث 2]
من الأسئلة؟ دعنا نحاول تصنيف هذا بشكل أكبر قليلاً. سابقاً، عرضت عليك قائمة
هنا بهذه الأسئلة المختلفة. السؤال الأول يقول، "ما هو أكثر مكان مثير للاهتمام
[المتحدث 2]
زرته على الإطلاق وما الذي جعله مميزاً؟" إذا أجبت على هذا السؤال هناك،
متى ستطرح هذا السؤال في محادثة؟
[المتحدث 1]
في أي نوع من المواقف؟
حسناً، أود أن أسأل شخصاً قابلته مؤخراً. نبدأ محادثة
[المتحدث 1]
تماماً كشيء لكسر الحاجز، أليس كذلك؟ وفقط لكسر الحاجز، سأبدأ محادثة
أقول فيها، حسناً، إذا رأيت أنهم مهتمون بهذا النوع من المحادثات.
[المتحدث 1]
ولكن، كما تعلم، من الشائع جداً أن تتحدث عن نفسك عندما يتم تقديمك
أو عندما تقدم نفسك لشخص ما، أليس كذلك؟ وأنت تبحث عن أسئلة أو،
[المتحدث 1]
كما تعلم، تاريخ يمكنك سرده.
[المتحدث 2]
من الرائع أن يكون لديك سؤال يمكنك الإجابة عليه
لأنك حينها تعرف ما يمكنك قوله. ولكنه يساعد الشخص الآخر أيضاً،
[المتحدث 2]
إذا كان بإمكانك طرح سؤال كهذا عليه أيضاً. يجعل المحادثة تسير
بشكل أكثر سلاسة. الأمر يسير في كلا الاتجاهين أيضاً.
[المتحدث 1]
نعم. وخاصة ذلك السؤال الذي أجبت عليه،
وهو الأول، لأنه، كما تعلم، تبدأ في التحدث عن أماكن عملك،
[المتحدث 1]
أليس كذلك؟ وإذا سألوني، أين عملت؟ فأخبرهم في المطار.
لذا يسألونني إذا كنت أسافر كثيراً، لأنني موظف في المطار،
[المتحدث 1]
يبدأون في طرح أسئلة من هذا القبيل. كنت أعمل في شركة طيران صغيرة جداً،
صحيح، تعمل فقط، رحلاتها محلية فقط هنا داخل البلاد. لذا كنت أتحدث عن
[المتحدث 1]
جزرنا، سان بيدرو سولا، وهي مكان في نقطة شمالية هنا في البلاد. وذلك فقط
لكسر الحاجز وبدء محادثة. عادةً ما أتحدث، أو أتحدث عن عائلاتهم،
[المتحدث 1]
من أين هم، وكل تلك الأشياء. فقط لكسر الحاجز. دائماً نفس الشيء.
[المتحدث 2]
هذا شيء تشعر بالراحة تجاهه حقاً. لقد أجريت هذه المحادثات
كثيراً باللغة الإنجليزية. لذا إذا احتجنا إلى الخروج قليلاً من منطقة الراحة،
[المتحدث 2]
ربما يمكننا طرح سؤال آخر من هذه الأسئلة. حسناً. إذا كان بإمكانك اختيار سؤال آخر
غير السؤال الأول، أي سؤال ستختار؟ ومتى ستطرح هذا السؤال؟
[المتحدث 2]
[المتحدث 1]
حسناً. دعني أقرأها مرة أخرى. أخبرني عن تحدٍّ تغلبت عليه.
ماذا تعلمت منه؟ ما هو الشيء الذي تتطلع إليه في المستقبل القريب؟
[المتحدث 1]
ما هي الهواية أو النشاط الذي تستمتع به وقد يجده الآخرون مفاجئاً؟ حسناً. أحد الأشياء
هو مجرد الحصول على وظيفة جديدة. هذا أحد تحدياتي، لأنه حتى لو كنت شخصاً متقدماً في السن،
[المتحدث 1]
لكنني بحاجة إلى إعالة نفسي. لست معتاداً على أن يعيلني شخص آخر.
لقد كنت دائماً المعيل، لذا أحتاج إلى الحصول على وظيفة بنفسي. وكان الأمر صعباً ومليئاً بالتحديات
[المتحدث 1]
بالنسبة لي، لأنه كما أخبرتك، أنا شخص متقدم في السن، وكما تعلم، الإمكانيات في بلدي،
ليست كثيرة جداً لأشخاص مثلي أو لشخص آخر في نفس عمري وأشياء من هذا القبيل.
[المتحدث 1]
ولكن، كما تعلم، كلما كنت مستعداً بشكل أفضل، كلما حصلت على وظيفة بشكل أسرع، أليس كذلك؟ ولكن حتى لو درست كثيراً
في بعض الأحيان ولديك الكثير من الخبرة، فهذا ليس كافياً في هذا البلد، لأن
[المتحدث 1]
لديك الكثير من المنافسة مع الشباب المستعدين جيداً لنوع الوظيفة التي قد نتقدم إليها.
[المتحدث 2]
يؤسفني حقاً أن أسمع أن الأمر كان صعباً للغاية.
أعلم أنه في العديد من الأماكن يمثل تحدياً للأشخاص المتقدمين في السن لإيجاد فرص متكافئة.
[المتحدث 2]
ولكن بعد التحدث معك عدة مرات في بضع دروس، يمكنني حقاً أن أقول إن لديك
بعض مهارات التواصل الرائعة. لديك بعض الخبرات المثيرة للإعجاب. ولو كنت صاحب عمل،
[المتحدث 2]
لكنت مهتماً حقاً بسيرتك الذاتية وخبرتك. لديك الكثير من الأشياء الرائعة لتقدمها،
وقد تواجه مشاكل في إيجاد فرص في هندوراس، لكنني لا أعتقد
[المتحدث 2]
أنك ستواجه أي نوع من المشاكل في إيجاد فرص في أماكن أخرى. أعتقد أنك
ستفعل ذلك. عليك فقط أن تؤمن بنفسك. لديك بعض المهارات الرائعة حقاً ومهارات التواصل.
[المتحدث 2]
أنا معجب جداً ببراعتك اللغوية.